the day after I posted my response he
went on stream and had a huge unhinged
tantrum and meltdown about the whole
holy bro you that I was just joking
about how he's a school yeah this man is
now dancing around with the hand with
pictures of people who said main things
about him on the internet look at you
want to be Tate the interesting you and
Tate is that you're in like a
tiny pillbox apartment you've been a
strange and alienated from everyone and
you're having a mental breakdown on the
internet for the whole world to see you
are not Andrew Tate he sucked the life
force out of you and left I think Andrew
Tate must be some kind of brain parasite
because like he's told he stole his life
force and left him an empty shell who's
in love with Andrew for making his life
up